(playful, twinkling music)
- [Narrator] This is Zana,
a Matschie's tree kangaroo.
She's adorable, isn't she?
But don't let her
adorableness deceive you.
This rare kangaroo is
extremely threatened.
(playful, twinkling music)
With curved claws and
stocky, muscular limbs,
she's at home in the trees.
However, her padded paws
allow her to fall from up to
60 feet without injury.
This marsupial is so rare,
it can only be found in
the mountainous rainforests
of northeastern Papua New Guinea.
It's a solitary creature that
spends most of its time alone,
except for when there's
a baby to care for.
Tree kangaroo joeys spend
18 months with their mothers
before setting out on their own.
Oil drilling and logging
are destroying the Matschie's habitat
and it's thick, beautiful
fur has made it an attractive
target for native hunters.
Captive breeding and
local education efforts
are making headway,
but it's future is uncertain.
This is the Matschie's tree kangaroo.
(playful, twinkling music)